2,911 CALLS REMAIN LARGELY
UNSEEN AND UNHEARD
>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER
WITH DETAILS, THANKS A LOT.
YOU REMEMBER BROWARD COUNTY
SHERIFF SCOTT ISRAEL, HE
DISCREDITED HIMSELF WITH THE
HANDLING OF THE PARKLAND
SHOOTING.
HE ATTEMPTED TO VILIFY GUN
OWNERS AS A GROUP WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY KEEPING CREDIT ON
HIMSELF.
NOW SHERIFF ISRAEL IS FACING A
VOTE OF NO CONFIDENCE FROM HIS
HIS OWN DEPUTIES.
AND PRESIDENT OF THE BROWARD
SHERIFF OFFICE AND HE JOINS US.
MR. BELL, THANK YOU FOR COMING
ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: WHY DO YOU HAVE NO
CONFIDENCE?
>> THERE IS A SERIES OF EVENTS
THAT HAVE LED UP TO THIS VOTE OF
NO CONFIDENCE AND IT HAS
SOMETHING TO DO WITH THE
CONTRACT WHATSOEVER.
THIS IS ABOUT THE SERIES OF
EVENTS OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS WITH A CIVIL CITATIONS
PROGRAM THAT TAKES ALL
DISCRETION AWAY FROM DEPUTIES TO
MAKE THE ARRESTS THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE.
IT'S ABOUT THE LACK OF TRAINING
FACILITIES, NOT HAVING OUR OWN
GUN RANGE TO PROPERLY TRAIN FOR
THESE SITUATIONS.
IT'S ABOUT THE DISTRESS BETWEEN
THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE AND THE
UNION WHEN THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE
ASKED FOR OUR HELP TO BE BRIEF.
WHEN WE COMPLETE AN AUDIT, THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE RETURNED
$100 MILLION BACK TO THE COUNTY
COMMISSION ALONE LAST YEAR.
THEN THERE'S THE DISCOVERY OF
THE MISUSE OF TAXPAYER MONEY TO
THE BROWARD SHERIFF'S OFFICE BY
PROVIDING PRIVATE ENTITIES SUCH
AS NAPA AUTO PARTS WITH FREE GAS
CARDS FROM THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE
WHERE WE HAVE IDENTIFIED THROUGH
PUBLIC RECORD REQUESTS THAT IN
ONE YEAR ALONE, THEY OBTAINED
6,000 GALLONS OF GASOLINE FROM
THEM.
ON TOP OF THIS, IT'S A DISPARITY
OF TREATMENT AND PUNISHMENT
BETWEEN THE COMMAND STAFF IF
THEY ARE TO COMMIT FELONIES AND
UNTRUTHFULNESS COMPARED TO A
DEPUTY HAS A --
>> Tucker: WHAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING IS THE COMBINATION OF
INCOMPETENCE AND CORRUPTION.
CALL ME CYNICAL, BUT WHEN YOU
WATCH SHERIFF ISRAEL LAY THE
ENTIRE BLAME FOR THE SHOOTING ON
MILLER AMERICA, ORDINARY
LAW-ABIDING PEOPLE HAVE TOO MANY
GUNS, DO YOU THINK THAT WAS AN
EFFORT TO DISTRACT FROM HIS OWN
FAILURES?
>> ABSOLUTELY ADVISE AND YOU CAN
SEE THE PATTERN OF THIS.
SHERIFF ISRAEL BACK IN HIS OWN
FACEBOOK POSTS FROM
FEBRUARY 24TH OF THIS YEAR, HE
SAID THERE'S ONE DEPUTY ON SCENE
FOR THE ENTIRE ATTACK.
HE CAN'T TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT
THAT EVENT, THEN HE GOES IN A
TOWN FORUM AND BLAMES THE NRA
AND HE BLAMES ONE DEPUTY SCOTT
PETERSON FOR THIS PROBLEM AND HE
BLAMES EVERYBODY ELSE THAT HE
CAN FOR THIS PROBLEM.
I UNDERSTAND THAT HE CAN'T BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR EVERY EMPLOYEE,
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, HE
NEEDS TO BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR HIS
EMPLOYEES AND HE'S NOT BEING
ACCOUNTABLE AND YES, THIS IS
SOME OF THE REASONS WHY HE NEEDS
TO BE REMOVED FROM OFFICE.
>> Tucker: ACCOUNTABILITY
REQUIRES TRANSPARENCY.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHAT SOMEONE'S
DOING IN ORDER TO EVALUATE IT
AND YOU JUST HEARD
TRACE GALLAGHER SAY THAT THERE
ARE MANY VIDEO AND AUDIO TAPES
OF THE PUBLIC HAS NOT SEEN, WHY
IS THAT?
>> THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
TRANSPARENT BECAUSE IT'S GOING
TO EXPOSE THAT THE SHERIFF KNEW
SOME INFORMATION IN THE PAST
THAT HE CONTRADICTED HIMSELF IN
PUBLIC INTERVIEWS.
NOW IT'S GOING TO COME BACK AND
BITE HIM.
HOWEVER, WE ARE GOING TO A
FAST-FORWARD FOR MORE
TRANSPARENCY WITH THE SHERIFF
THE SAME WAY HE CLAIMS TO BE THE
MOST TRANSPARENT SURE IF THAT'S
EVER BEEN IN THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE.
IT GOES BOTH WAYS AND YOU NEED
TO BE TRANSPARENT.
RELEASE THOSE VIDEOS SO WE CAN
KNOW THE TRUTH.
IF THERE IS A VOTE OF NO
CONFIDENCE ECHOES FORWARD AND IT
TURNS OUT THE WAY THAT THE
MEMBERSHIP IS VOICING THEIR
OPINIONS FOR IT, WILL TAKE THAT
INFORMATION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND WILL SUPPORT HIM WITH
WHATEVER DECISION HE WANTS TO
MAKE, BUT IF HE CHOOSES TO
REMAIN SHERIFF WITH SCOTT
ISRAEL, THEN THAT MEANS THAT THE
GOVERNOR AGREES THAT
SHERIFF ISRAEL IS AN AMAZING
LEADER, WHICH HE IS.
BE FOREWARNED THAT WHEN THAT
INCIDENT HAPPENS, IF THE
GOVERNOR LEAVES THEM THERE, IT
WILL BE ON THE HANDS OF
GOVERNOR SCOTT, NOT THE
EMPLOYEES OF THE BROWARD
SHERIFF'S OFFICE.
>> Tucker: I'M SO GLAD YOU'RE
BRINGING THIS TO OUR ATTENTION.
IT'S A SHAME THAT WE HAD TO WAIT
MONTHS TO HEAR IT FROM A
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND
CNN, WHICH HOSTED THIS
GUN-CONTROL RALLY AND PUT ISRAEL
AT THE CENTER OF IT, NEVER ASK A
SINGLE SKEPTICAL QUESTION ABOUT
HIS BEHAVIOR.